today on the matt walsh show the left
screams in horror as a case challenging
row heads to the supreme court they say
that women's rights are under attack but
how can they even talk about women's
rights given that according to them
women don't really exist
also is roe likely to be overturned and
what happens if it is we'll tackle all
that today plus
five headlines including fauci finally
admitting that he's been masking for
symbolic reasons basically
and the ties between bill gates and
jeffrey epstein come into focus
after months of the media canonizing
gates and insisting that we trust and
listen to him
now they're talking about about epstein
and all these other things in our daily
cancellation we will talk about
the recent push to convince us to eat
bugs
should we start eating crickets and
cockroaches instead of bacon and
hamburgers
we'll consider that question today and
much more on the matt wall show
[Music]
in our age of hyperbole every supreme
court case
is treated as something monumental and
history shaping
occasionally that's actually true though
and that might be this might be one of
those occasions
as cnn reported on monday quote the
supreme court on monday agreed to take
up a key abortion case next term
concerning a controversial mississippi
law that banned most abortions after
15 weeks rekindling a potentially major
challenge to roe v wade at the majority
uh conservative court supposedly
majority conservative court we'll get to
that a second
anyway cnn says mississippi's 15-week
abortion ban which then governor phil
bryant a republican signed into law in
2018
made exceptions only for medical
emergencies or cases in which there is a
quote severe fetal abnormality
but not for instances of rape or incest
a federal judge in mississippi struck
down the law november 2018
and the fifth u.s circuit court of
appeals upheld that ruling in december
2019
after being rescheduled for the court's
consideration and conference over a
dozen times the case
would could present a direct challenge
to roe v wade the 1973 landmark supreme
court decision legalizing abortion
nationwide prior to viability which can
occur at around 24 weeks of pregnancy
all right now of course viability in
this context refers to the
unborn child's ability to survive
outside the womb
that threshold can be reached at 24
weeks even earlier than 24 weeks in some
cases and it's being lowered
with each passing year as technology
improves because that's really what this
is about
the the viability quote unquote is about
modern technology it's not about the the
child
but really the concept of viability is a
misnomer in truth
no child is truly viable in the sense
they can
survive on their own until many years
after birth
for some people these days they haven't
even reached that point by their i don't
know 30th birthday
the point is that babies outside of the
womb require
constant attention and care from their
parents yeah they can breathe
and that's that sort of thing on their
own can they survive on their own
no and that's that's not a that's that's
you know that's not a small point
because parents
are obligated by law to provide the care
to their children
that their children need and if they
don't provide that care
then they have to find someone else who
will if they fail to meet that
obligation
or certainly if they simply just kill
their child to save themselves the
burden
they'll go to prison and that and that
kicks in
the moment the child is born that child
is born
and is quote unquote viable but still
cannot do anything
on his own cannot survive on his own
needs to be cared for
every second of the day and if those
parents do not provide that care
refuse to and don't find anyone else who
will they go to jail
now there's no reason why we should
force parents to care for their born
children but not their pre-born children
it's the same person after all and
they're just as much the parents at both
stages
but this is just one of the many
arbitrary distinctions that the
pro-abortion side has made
and rested their leg their legal case
upon
as for that legal case i must say
the pessimist or perhaps just the
realist in me is quite skeptical that
this court with its current makeup will
arrive at any decision
any decision that overturns or severely
curtails roe
i pray they do obviously but i'm not
gonna
buy the champagne and the confetti
confetti ahead of time
um that's a financial investment that i
think probably won't pay off
the media claims that there are well
what they tell us is that there are six
conservatives on the court
it's a 6-3 super conservative majority
court
in reality there are only what two
with a track record of being
conservative supreme court justice
perhaps one or two of the three that
trump appointed will be added to that
list eventually but
that remains to be seen there certainly
aren't six
and almost certainly are not five um
you know i i i don't think that the
so-called abortion
that so-called abortion rights really
hang in the balance for that reason
as much as i wish they did but we'll see
we should also stipulate and this
shouldn't need to be explained but
it has to be that overturning roe
would not lead automatically to abortion
being illegal in every state
abortion should be illegal in every
state but that's not what would happen
as a direct
consequence of of roe being overturned
if it ever was
all that would happen is that each state
would be empowered now to make its own
laws on the issue
this is a situation that even a
pro-abortion person if they were honest
and i'm not sure that any such creature
actually exists an honest pro-abortion
person
kind of a uh you know a contradiction
contradiction in terms but even if if
such a person did exist
they should prefer that because you can
be in favor of legal abortion
while still recognizing that roe was a
bad decision
the justices managed to locate a right
to abortion
in the constitution even though no such
right is ever mentioned or even hinted
at in the constitution
and they found it within the right to
privacy
which is also not mentioned in the
constitution
so if you're keeping track at home that
is two degrees of removal from the
constitution
the right to abortion is a non-existent
constitutional right
grounded in another non-existent
constitutional right
the justices may have just claimed that
they they may as well just claim they
discovered a secret decoder ring and
found the right
to abortion written in code or written
in invisible ink or something
that would have been somehow more
credible than what they actually claimed
it was just a bad decision on legal
grounds again
no matter how you feel about abortion
it's a bad decision
and that's why roe should be overturned
whether or not it actually will be
we'll see now as far as why abortion
itself should be illegal
everywhere for everyone in all cases
that's simply because
unborn humans are human
and abortion is the intentional and
direct destruction
of those humans and it's always wrong to
intentionally and directly destroy
innocent human life okay that's that's
the argument it's pretty simple
unborn and every single step of this
this is a self-evident this is morally
and logically self-evident this argument
because every single step of it is
clearly true
unborn humans are human
that cannot be denied that's a
scientific fact
abortion directly destroys those humans
kills them again cannot be denied that's
the whole point of the abortion
so if you're gonna quibble with any part
of this then i guess what you would have
to quibble with
is the assertion that it's necessarily
wrong
to intentionally and directly destroy
innocent human life
and if you're going to quibble with that
then that has implications far beyond
the womb
i mean i have to ask if you know if it
actually can be okay to directly and
intentionally destroy
innocent human life then um
what other innocent human life can you
destroy
but if you're of the opinion that it's
wrong to intentionally directly destroy
innocent human life and almost everyone
on earth would at least claim to believe
that then there's no way to get around
the fact that abortion is a moral
atrocity
okay so that's that's abortion that's
roe v wade
there's another aspect of this
discussion that i think also has to be
brought up
in response to the news about the court
taking up this case we've heard
all of the panic and outrage and seen
all of the performative
hand-wringing that you would expect
we've been told this is an assault on
women's rights in an evasion
of women's privacy an attack on women's
bodily autonomy etc and so forth
the lieutenant governor of illinois
tweeted the typical tripe that we always
see
she said say the word abortion i'm over
these folks who want to legislate my
uterus
we know what's best for our bodies and
our futures and it's our choice
abortionist health care
like illinois's reproductive health act
we must fight to protect the right to
safe legal abortion
yes abortion is health care in the same
way that a meat packing plant
is a veterinary clinic but
that's not the point right now the point
is that the the language here
the language that the pro boards
continue to use
like joy reid for example on msnbc she
invoked in a segment last night she
invoked the handmaid's tale
which makes me wonder by the way what
the country might look like if leftists
would read some other book besides that
and harry potter
but in any case here's uh here's what
she said about that listen
terrifying prospect eerily reminiscent
of the handmaid's tale
where far right-wing religious
extremists took up arms against america
to carve out their own country out of
ours one where women
and their bodies were under the complete
control of almost
extravagantly corrupt and hypocritical
men of god
quote unquote and what's so scary and
frankly traumatizing about that show
and the book that inspired it is that it
starts off in the very place
that we live in right now where women
have the right to choose what they do
with their bodies
until they don't and then in what seemed
like a blink of an eye those rights
were just gone so what's the problem
here
well aside from the general inanity and
absurdity of these
silly feminists who think that they're
being enslaved if they aren't allowed to
dismember their children
aside from that the problem as i feel i
must continue to point out whenever
given the opportunity
is that they're no longer allowed to
make arguments
like this allowed according to their own
rules not mine
women's rights women's health an attack
on women blah blah et cetera
as a feminist on the left you have lost
all of those talking points you
forfeited them you gave them up you
tossed them out the window
that's what you did i mean women aren't
the only ones who can get pregnant
remember
this has nothing to do with women
specifically
uterus who says that only people with
uteruses can get pregnant
are you suggesting that a trans woman
without a uterus somehow
fundamentally lacks one of the essential
qualities of womanhood i mean you need
to sit here right now and say that
no trans woman can ever get pregnant how
dare you
you can't say that because that would be
to admit that there's an essential
difference between
a trans woman and a regular woman
and that would be to admit that trans
women well aren't really women at all
because there's an essential difference
between them and
and and other women
so you can't do that you can't admit
that
see your ideological commitments no
longer permit you to talk about women's
rights at
all there are no women or if there are
women they're not in any way
fundamentally distinguishable from men
we're all stranded out here
in the same ambiguous haze
now does that mean that you can't still
make a pro-abortion argument no you
could still be pro-abortion at the end
of the day
all pro-abortion arguments are bad and
stupid so what does it matter which you
use but if you're gonna
you are gonna have to recalibrate your
whole approach
and i'm gonna have to insist on that for
decades
your strategy rather than intellectually
engaging
with the issue and engaging with the
arguments like the one that i just laid
out the pro-life argument
which is that unborn humans are human
and that abortion intentionally directly
destroys them and intentionally directly
destroying innocent human life is always
wrong
rather than engaging with that your
strategy has been to cast women
as the victims of pro-life efforts
to victimize yourself identity politics
all of that that doesn't work anymore
you can't very well be a victim when you
don't exist
and i'm afraid to say women don't exist
not according to me according to you
so you have to go back to the drawing
board and figure this thing out
because what you're doing right now is
just not working anymore
i hate to tell you now let's get to our
five headlines
now i want to tell you about x chair you
know when it comes to chairs
i am i'm a chair snob i admit i'm like
princess in the p or goldilocks i'm not
sure which fairy tale i should be using
here but the point is
i have very specific chair related needs
especially because i spent so much of
the time sitting down unfortunately
and that's why i'm so happy to finally
have an ex-chair extra has you covered
with all your office chair needs
the secret is not only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support which
offers unbelievable
lumbar support to your lower back but
now thanks to their new xhmt technology
you can also get heat and massage
therapy while you're sitting at your
desk you get all of that
in this chair it's a it's a massager
it's an office chair it's everything all
rolled into one
instead of your old uncomfortable office
chair now you can look forward to
spending hours sitting in the ultimate
therapeutic massager the xhmt delivers
heat massage technology right to your
core helping increase blood flow
muscle recovery and energy all the perks
that make working from home
or office a joy um x chair is on sale
now for a hundred dollars off so go to
xchairwalsh.com that's the letter x
chair walsh.com or call one eight four
four four x chair
extra has a 30 day guarantee of complete
comfort and you can finance your
purchase for as little as 30 bucks a
month go to
xchairwalsh.com now use codex wheels for
free x wheel bladecasters
xchairwalsh.com i endured a great trial
recently
my son is very into superheroes now
which is great
um going through a big superhero phase
and i love superheroes too when i was
his age
and you know i want to show interest in
the things that he's interested in so i
sat down with him
on sunday night to watch uh the event we
all watched as a family actually watched
the avengers and the first one
and i've never i never i've never seen
any avengers movies
and i know that i'm like 10 years late i
guess but uh but i never saw them
because i didn't before now i didn't
have kids that were old enough to watch
them
and i wasn't going to go and watch them
myself because i'm a
what do you call a grown man so i wasn't
expecting much
but man are these movies terrible
so but really really bad i thought
they'd be bad but they were even worse
than i thought
i didn't say that to my son but between
you and me long dull
repetitive there are no stakes right
even though the world is hanging in the
balance there's actually no stakes
nothing is at stake because everybody is
indestructible
until the moment when the script needs
them to not be indestructible
so like the hulk for example he can he
can pick up a tank
and rip it in half and throw a piece of
it into orbit
but then he punches captain america
directly in the head doesn't even cause
a concussion
and then at another point captain
america like slips on a banana peel and
is knocked unconscious for three days
i'm paraphrasing the movie slightly but
the point is
that their indestructibility fluctuates
wildly depending on what is needed for
that particular scene
and that just makes it boring it's like
watching a video game and it's
long it's so long too these long drawn
out scenes of these one-dimensional
cardboard characters whining about their
feelings
speaking of the hulk you know the movie
is 18 hours long
and the hulk is actually the hulk for 12
seconds and my son is sitting all he
wants to see is the hulk
break stuff but instead he's watching
mark ruffalo
take anger management classes this is
not who is this supposed to appeal to
you don't have the actors or the script
to turn this into a character drama
so if it's going to be a mindless orgy
of punching and shooting then just
pick a lane and go with that really bad
how do adults watch this
there are grown adults who don't even
have a kid it's not like this is a
sacrifice to make it for their kids they
watch it on their own what are you
doing i will admit the one thing i liked
in the movie was scarlett johansson's
character
uh because she was so useless it's
hilarious
you've got these immortal gods and
superhuman creatures
and then they team up with a woman who's
as far as i can tell she's just
she's a she's a moderately athletic
woman
why would you need her on the team it's
like if they're if the top nine scorers
in the nba
were playing pickup basketball and the
team with four
needed a fifth guy so they got me to
come and play
like you'd definitely be better off with
just four of you than having me on the
court because i'd be a liability
but then again i guess there's the
affirmative action and all that which
even with superhero teams they have to
worry about
um so just terrible stuff it's it's a
shame
that adults this these are this should
be just for kids
and even for kids it's not that great
okay where were we all right number one
a reporter uh during the white house
press briefing
talking about the masking and everything
the reporter was concerned and you know
maybe you can
if you could put yourself into the mind
of a race-obsessed
left-wing reporter maybe you can make
sense of this because i really can't
but she's concerned that that that
telling people they don't have to wear
masks anymore
might be racist let's let's let's hear
her out
the largest national nurses union is
saying that
the cdc guidelines on mass is putting
frontline workers
and especially people of color at risk
and that they're they're calling for the
cdc to reverse that what's the
white house's stance on that union in
particular saying that
they're their members and people of
color at risk well i would say we don't
have any particular response to directly
to the union
uh i'm not going to show you the whole
rambling response from
uh jen saki there but it puts
particularly people of color at risk why
in reality it doesn't put anyone at risk
of course but
if it was gonna put anyone at risk why
people of color this is
it's a rhetorical question on my part i
i know the the why
it's it's it's instinct on the part of
uh
the media and people on the left it's
just everything
if if they have a problem with anything
if there's anything they're opposed to
then or anything they think is bad
they're going to immediately assume that
it's also racist
and they're not going to bother even in
their own minds to sort that out and
figure out
why is this racist they just assume that
it is
it's all instinctive now for more
masking news the mayor of chicago
uh is she was interviewed and she said
that she
she was on msnbc she said that she she
respects of course the
cdc um and uh the cdc's guidance
but she's going to reject it here's why
you say you will follow the cdc's
guidance
what does that mean should people in
chicago wear masks or not
well i think we've got to get some
clarification from the cdc
um the rollout obviously is the
reporting has been
was a bit abrupt um and i think they've
got a lot of clarification that they
need to do
um i know for me personally i'm going to
continue to wear a mask in public
and i'm going to encourage others to do
so we've got to make sure
that people are continuing to follow the
public health guidance that has gotten
us this far
and mask i think are a big and important
part of that to say
well if you're if you're vaccinated you
don't have to wear a mask that's great
but what about all the other people that
are out there that aren't vaccinated
and there's no way to know that so i
think for the time being
most people are going to continue to
wear masks
outside and outside of their homes and i
think that's smart
well she's saying outside of your home
so outdoors indoors
you leave your home wear the mask
because of unvaccinated people
yes there are unvaccinated people out
there but if you're vaccinated
and the vaccines work which you say they
do
then why are you worried about the
unvaccinated people
what difference does that make they're
not going to get you sick
you're not going to get them sick well
let me clarify they might still get you
sick and you might get them sick
just not of covet there's a million
other things out there
yeah i've been saying that all along
um we uh we think that we
conquer covet and now we're immortal
which is why i do kind of laugh when i'm
and i shouldn't laugh about this at all
but i kind of imagine
it would be sort of funny a little bit
if somebody
you know they go and they get the covet
vaccine and uh then cdc makes the
announcement and says you can take the
mask off and yeah we got past the
pandemic and so i was like i'm immortal
now i'm fine
and uh they just got the vaccine they
walk out
of walgreens and then they immediately
get hit by a bus
and die it's like it's a little funny to
imagine a little bit
because the threats are still out there
there's still a million threats and
something's still gonna kill you
but as far as covid goes um
why should you worry about the
unvaccinated people from your own
using your own logic
now speaking of people who are still
wearing the mask we talked about this i
i wanted to read this to you
proving the point that i opened the show
with yesterday and i wish i had read
this because this was an article in the
new york times
that was published a couple days ago i
just didn't see it before i did that
monologue yesterday i wish i had seen it
perfectly proving the point let me read
a little bit of this to you this is from
the new york times it says quote
whenever joe glickman heads out for
groceries he places an n95 mask over his
face and tugs a cloth mask on top of it
he then pulls on a pair of goggles so
two masks and goggles every time he goes
out to go grocery shopping
he has used this safety protocol for the
past 14 months it did not change after
he contracted the coronavirus in
november it did not budge win earlier
this month
he became fully vaccinated and even
though president joe biden said on
thursday
that fully vaccinated people do not have
to wear a mask glickman said he planned
to stay the course
in fact he said he plans to do his
grocery run double masked and goggled
for at least the next
five years even as a combination of
evolving public health recommendations
and pandemic fatigue
leave more americans to toss the masks
they have worn for more than a year
glickman
is among those who say they plan to keep
their faces covered in public
indefinitely
for people like glickman a combination
of anxiety murky information about new
virus variants
and the emergence of a sizable faction
of vaccine holdouts means
mask-free life is on hold possibly
forever
glickman a professional photographer a
musician from new york said quote i have
no problem being one of the only people
but i don't think i'm going to be the
only one
and then it continues but
this guy double masked with goggles
fully vaccinated
this is in in any other
time you saw just imagine
a year and a half ago seeing a guy
like that with goggles and two masks on
at the grocery store
and assuming you knew that he had no
other major health concerns
what would you think of of that guy you
would think that he's insane you would
think that this is someone suffering
certainly clinical hypochondria ocd
this is someone who should be in a
mental institution this is someone who's
a danger to himself and others
potentially
this is a mentally unbalanced lunatic
that would be everyone's assumption a
year and a half ago
and you know what you it's correct now
too
but what i love most about this is that
he says he got
he got the virus back in november
so he did all of that and he still got
the virus this guy was walking around in
two masks and
goggles for 14 months and he still got
it
and yet it doesn't click he doesn't make
the the uh the connection here hmm
i still got it maybe this everything i'm
doing here isn't really working it's
unnecessary
so he got it and and he was already
immune from that and then he got the
virus
the vaccine on top of it
my lord it's hard to even um
on one hand you want to laugh at these
people because they're absurd
and they deserve to be laughed at but on
the other hand it's
incredibly disturbing
one other thing here on the on the
masking i just want to play this for you
dr fauci interviewed on tv yet again his
favorite thing to do
um he's he's saying that he's not
wearing the mask indoors anymore
and he's asked why you know he was
wearing it to begin with indoors after
getting vaccinated
and uh this is this is the reason that
he gives
how has it changed what you do how does
it change your math scoring practices
well you know george i'm obviously
careful because
i mean i'm a physician and a health care
provider i am now much more comfortable
in in people seeing me indoors without a
mask i mean
before the cdc made the recommendation
change
i didn't want to look like i was giving
mixed signals but being a fully
vaccinated person
the chances of my getting infected in an
indoor setting
is extremely low and that's the reason
why in indoor settings now
i feel comfortable about not wearing a
mask because i'm fully man
i'm fully vaccinated okay so he says
there that he doesn't need the mask he's
not wearing it now
why did he wear it before because he
didn't want to send mixed
signals which is another way of saying
that he was wearing it for
show he was wearing it for symbolic
reasons he was wearing it as theaters
theatrical
uh he admits that there so now i want to
go back
to the the ancient past of two months
ago
when um rand paul was questioning valjey
and said that wearing masks when you're
fully vaccinated is theater
and at the time dr fauci wasn't quite
ready to admit that let's watch that
you're telling everybody to wear a mask
whether they've had an infection or a
vaccine what i'm saying is they have
immunity and everybody agrees they have
immunity what studies do you have
that people who have had the vaccine or
have had the infection are spreading the
infection if we're not spreading the
infection
isn't it just theater no it's not a
vaccine and you're wearing two masks
isn't that theater no that's not here we
go again with the theater
let's get down to the facts okay the
studies that you
quote from crotty and sete
look at in vitro examination of memory
immunity which in their paper they
specifically
say this does not necessarily pertain to
the actual protection it's in vitro
and what study can you point to that
shows significant reinfection there are
no studies that show just
let me let me finish the response to
your question
if you please the other thing is that
when you talk about reinfection
and you don't keep in the concept of
variance
that's an entirely different ball game
so that was him two months ago it's not
a year ago it's two months ago we're
talking march 2020 that's march 2021
and he'd say oh here we go again with
the theater it's not that at all and
then fast forward two months and you say
yeah it was all theater
just a liar all of these people lying
like they breathe i don't even know if
they can tell anymore when they're lying
okay next moving on here you may recall
how bill gates was
effectively canonized certainly over the
past year but
probably for much longer than that we
were supposed to
listen to bill gates about the
coronavirus it was never really
explained why
we should listen to this guy is he an
expert on this what is it what does his
opinion matter
i know he's got a lot of money he's very
rich but does that make him an expert on
does that make him an epidemiologist
also
but we were supposed to listen to him
trust him implicitly
but that all changed and rapidly so
after news that he and his wife were
getting divorced and now there's
just an avalanche of um
stories coming out about bill gates
um including this one this is probably
the most the most damning
this is from the new york post it says
jeffrey epstein
jeffrey epstein reportedly gave advice
to bill gates about ending his marriage
with his now estranged wife
melinda during meetings the two had at
the pedophile's manhattan townhouse
epstein who killed himself in august
2019 allegedly
in a lower manhattan jail cell gave
gates some pointers about what the
microsoft co-founder
called his toxic marriage to melinda
epstein and gates met dozens of times
but from 2011 to 2014 the report said
with gates treating the get-togethers as
an escape a person who attended some of
the meetings told the publication
most of the gatherings occurred at
epstein's upper east side pad
a source told the outlet quote it's not
an overstatement going to jeffries was a
respite from his marriage it was a way
of getting away from melinda
during some of the meetings gates spoke
to epstein about possibly getting
involved with the bill and melinda gates
foundation
but a spokesperson for bill gates denied
the allegations in a statement to the
daily beast quote bill never received
her solicited personal advice of any
kind from epstein on marriage or
anything else
bill never complained about melinda or
his marriage step scene according to the
spokesperson
uh okay a few things here number one
of all people why are you consulting
jeffrey epstein for marriage advice
he's uh he's a bachelor
a pedophile sex trafficker
and you're a billionaire and you can
consult anyone in the world and he's the
guy you go to for marriage advice
that's interesting um
number two we know that that all of this
stuff of course we can assume is coming
from melinda's camp
and she's got she's got a pr team that's
um
like if you're if you're a billionaire
getting divorced fi find melinda gates's
pr team because they're doing
they're doing some work here but third
you know this just
goes to show this is the media
yet again as i said canonizing someone
and then
changing course it's not even as though
changing course over the over a period
of years or something there's this
gradual
change in the way we're supposed to view
this person it's a sudden shift
here's this is from the daily wire uh it
says former brooklyn center police
department officer
kim potter who shouted taser moments
before fatally shooting a 20-year-old
man who appeared to be resisting arrest
according to the video of the
altercation will stand trial for
manslaughter
at the end of this year according to a
hennepin county judge
according to the washington post
henneman county judge regina chu said
that potter will be scheduled for trial
in december in connection with dante
wright's death
potter who served on the police force
for 26 years before resigning
was charged with second-degree
manslaughter mere days after the fateful
altercation with wright so they're
moving forward with this pretty quickly
she was the one you remember we don't
need to play the clip again but she was
the one
well starting with dante wright was the
one who allegedly
committed an armed robbery of a woman
choked her in the process
and there was a warrant out for his
arrest
and he was stopped for traffic violation
they saw the warrant
tried to arrest him he resisted arrest
climbed back into his car
and then kim potter shouted taser but
didn't pull the taser
shot him and then said oh crap uh
admitting
basically on camera that it was a
mistake and then dante wright died now
she's being charged with uh
with manslaughter the interesting thing
about this case
is that it seems to me from a legal
perspective
ironically if it wasn't if she had done
it on purpose and it said from the
beginning that she did it on purpose
i think she would have a more persuasive
legal case
i think they'd still be bringing her up
on charges because that's just the way
these things go now
innocent or not is they're gonna they're
gonna bring you up on charges if you're
a cop
and you kill someone um
in the course of an arrest but i think
if she if she had said for if it was
intentional if she had said from the
beginning that was intentional
then she'd have a very good case because
he's someone wanted for armed robbery
so this is a alleged violent a suspected
violent criminal
he's resisting or as he's climbing back
into his car
he could be reaching for you don't know
what he's going to do he could be
reaching for something also keep in mind
his vehicle is a weapon and this happens
frequently that vehicles are used as
weapons against police officers
during the course of an arrest and not
only that but
um even if he's not reaching for a
weapon
he gets back into the car goes on a high
speed chase now
the community is put at risk who knows
what could happen from there
so i think she could have had a real
case for shooting him on purpose for all
of those reasons
but she admitted it was an accident so
that goes out the window
and then you think about okay well it
was an accident does that mean she
should be charged with manslaughter and
i would say even there no
i don't think she should drop on charges
it was a mistake
and um you know you could think of it
similar to medical mistakes
thousands of medical mistakes happen
every year and people are people die
because of them
and you don't normally hear about
surgeons and doctors going to jail
because of it
even though somebody died and it's a
terrible thing
a life was lost but we also understand
that these are life or death things and
we we
we have doctors involved in these
situations
and if we tell them that hey listen if
anything goes wrong here you're going to
go to prison
well then you're probably not gonna end
up with a lot of doctors at the end of
the day
so i would put it in that category i
think it was a mistake like that it was
clearly a mistake
but why did it happen yeah it was a
mistake on her
end but it happened because dante wright
took it and that he resisted arrest he's
again
suspected violent criminal resisting
arrest climbing back into his car
he you're taking your life into your
hands when you do that
so he is the one who took this situation
from a peaceful
non-lethal situation they were in the
process of arresting him
and they would have just put him in the
car and taken him to jail and he could
he can fight the charges
in court like you're supposed to his
life was not in jeopardy at all
until he made the decision that he made
so he is the one who created this
situation
he is the one who put kim potter in the
position
where she could make a mistake like that
so if you want to put cops in a position
where they could make a fatal mistake
then don't do that i mean don't be a
violent criminal to begin with is
probably the best
best course of action but then if you
are and they come to arrest you
as as they're supposed to um don't
resist the rest and start reaching
around for things
in a fair and just society i think
that's what we would do
you take kim potter you take her off the
force obviously do you need to put her
in prison
is she is she a threat to the public is
anyone worried that she's
a danger to the public
you take her off the force it's not
she's not a danger to the public
i don't see how justice is served by by
sending her to prison
what's achieved by you know you put her
in prison for 10 years okay what does
that achieve
i we can assume that she's already
distraught
by this that her life is already ruined
like there's probably nothing you could
do to make her feel worse about it
and where does the fault lie ultimately
or rather where does the fault begin
it begins with dante wright
all that to say yeah that's how it
should be but how is it actually going
to be how it actually is going to be is
that she's probably going to go to jail
for 10 years
if not longer all right moving on to uh
reading
youtube comments this is from andrea she
says when matt yells at us to hit the
like button we get a small taste of his
kids lives
pray for them well you're right andre i
do yell at my kids to
like my youtube videos um that is
they're they're they they know that
anytime i post a youtube video they
better go on their accounts and like it
immediately
anytime i see them hey kids did you like
my youtube video did you see my new
content
you didn't like it yet no dinner until
you like my youtube videos
that's the way things are run in my
house uh
another comment says if you don't want
to wear a mask simply stop wearing one
you'd be surprised how few people will
say anything to you but if they do tell
them you have medical reasons not to
wear one by law
they're not permitted to question you
about your medical status
um well it's it's been the case all
along that people need to take charge of
their own lives
i would say this especially not just
about you but also your kids
people that are still sending their kids
out there wearing masks
claiming that they're following local
ordinances or the rules of different
establishments
um at a certain point you have to just
do the right thing
whether you have permission to or not uh
kimberly says so now my dating profile
will not only say
must not love dogs it will say must not
wear masks
kimberly you have your head on your
shoulders and your priorities straight
well done um matthew says i look forward
to a day when my children will not be
judged by a mask on their face but by
the content of their character
well to be clear i don't judge children
for their mask at all i judge their
parents
and uh james says hey matt i just
realized that bigfoot and the aliens are
like the tooth fairy in santa claus for
adults
how dare you sir you are banned from the
show
you could say that about that kind of
slander is allowed for bigfoot because
i'm pretty sure he doesn't exist but
aliens
and you might want to be really careful
what you say
considering they're here and they're
listening
and finally on bigfoot neon white says
every year over
15 million people buy hunting licenses
and go out into the woods with guns to
kill things if bigfoot was real there's
a 100 chance
that someone would have shot one by now
uh yeah not a 100 chance but
i put it like there's like an 80 chance
at least so that's
one of the reasons among many why i i
unfortunately i can't believe in bigfoot
but i'm
still open to being convinced if anyone
wants to try
you know i don't know about you but uh
my idea of a good time
is not spending hours
at an auto parts store sometimes i'm not
sure what my idea of a good time
actually is
but uh it's definitely not at an auto
parts store and that's why i'm so happy
to have rockauto.com it's so much easier
than walking into a store and someone
demanding quick answers
uh you might not know the answer to and
then they usually just have to order the
part online anyway because even if you
can answer their questions they're not
going to have what you need they order
the part
cut out the middleman go to rockauto.com
yourself you've got your phone in your
pockets pull it out go to rockauto.com
they always offer the lowest prices
possible they're not going to change
prices
and and also it's a really easy site to
navigate you can quickly find what
you're looking for
and you're going to see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands the specifications and the
parts you prefer
and listen they're a family business
they've been uh serving customers online
for 20 years
so if you need auto parts go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car
truck and as always we tell you remember
to write walsh in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
and not everyone has the privilege of
getting to know the one and only candace
owens
live and in person but that might be
about to change
for you if you sign up as a daily wire
member with code vip you'll also get 20
off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip to the daily wire studios to
see candace live not only will be
meeting candace
you'll be getting an inside look at her
studio our office in front row seats to
watch her live and in action on her talk
show candace
and also we should mention if you come
here you're going to be in the general
vicinity
of one matt walsh as well you're not
going to meet me but i'll be around
you may walk the ground that i walked
upon
that's a that's a perk you gotta admit
so don't wait go to enter uh to win a
candace vip pass now at dailywire.com
walsh subscribe that is it's
dailywire.com slash subscribe this is
all about me all the time
using code vip for 20 off and for an
experience
that only joe biden could forget rimshot
now let's get to our daily cancellation
one of the most boring news events that
we have to endure every
17 years is the emergence of the cicadas
when they crawl out of their underground
layer to wreak havoc across the land all
at the behest of
the evil wizard soramon i may be
confusing them with orcs from lord of
the rings come to think of it but in any
case
the whole thing always ends up being a
dud the cicadas are hyped up for years
and then they come out
they fly around for a little bit and
they die the only thing that makes this
year's cicada batch a little bit more
interesting is that this time
there are a bunch of freaks out there in
the media trying to convince us to eat
them
this headline on wired.com is typical it
says the cicadas are coming let's eat
them
why not embrace brood x as the
free-range sustainable source of protein
that it truly is
popular sciences headline says the brood
x cicadas are coming and we should and
you should eat them here's how
and the new york post says eating trendy
brewed ex cicadas
what the bug recipes taste like now i'm
not sure how the cicadas themselves are
trendy
i've never really thought of bugs in
that way but
if you're wondering what these recipes
are well wjz
in baltimore had a report a few days ago
featuring a johns hopkins doctor giving
some
tips on how to prepare your cicada snack
so
uh so here's that all right cicadas look
soon gonna be buzzing around
everywhere in our area it's gonna be fun
this was inevitable
one expert at johns hopkins says they
make cicadas that is
for a very tasty and eco-friendly meal
stetson miller has this for us
cicadas will soon be crawling all over
maryland
trillions of them in our backyards and
trees believe it or not that means
a lot of opportunities to try out a new
snack according to one johns hopkins
professor
they're a lot like shrimp they're like
tree shrimp sustainable food expert
jessica fonzo is planning to collect and
eat cicadas herself and wants you to
know that they're a great source of
protein
and also great for the environment we're
in the middle of climate change
insects there are a great alternative
source to
other animal source foods which for
example cows which are producing a lot
of greenhouse gas emissions
if you're brave enough to try one she
says you should pick out the nymphs
while they're still white
the ones that have just come out of the
ground and only eat the females
you can then freeze them in a bag and
when you're ready to eat boil them first
for two minutes
and then cook them to your liking you
can roast them in the oven
put some salt and pepper on there some
some
old bay seasoning on them
there's even a free cookbook online
dedicated to cicada dishes called
cicadalicious professor fonzo is urging
people to give them a try as an
alternative
green source of food it only comes
around once every 17 years
now first of all i have to say claiming
that they taste like shrimp
is not a selling point to me shrimp are
hideous
foul-tasting tiny little mutant beasts
themselves
they live in the they live in the dark
depths of the ocean ten thousand feet
under water
they're so they're tiny and gross and
ugly and god put them in the ocean deep
down
basically a bright neon sign from heaven
saying don't eat this crap and yet we
didn't catch the hint
we still scoop them up shovel them into
our fat faces so cicadas are like shrimp
not helping your case if true
but it's not true bugs don't taste like
shrimp
they taste like bugs i i've eaten some
bugs i've had crickets you can go to my
instagram right now
and see the video do you know what the
crickets tasted like
they tasted exactly like you think a
cricket would taste
there is no surprise the moment you eat
a bug
your immediate reaction is yep that's a
bug
and your second reaction is oh lord all
of its limbs are now stuck in my teeth
it's not a pleasant experience but it's
one that our cultural overlords
want us to have more often the push to
eat bugs has been going on for a while
now it's got big money behind it
speaking of bill gates the bill gates
foundation has been promoting
bug harvesting for a long time though i
sincerely doubt that gates himself has
ever sat down to a bowl of
beetle soup the guardian had a lengthy
article a few days ago titled
if we want to save the planet the future
of food is insects
fried crickets on the school menu milk
made from fly not larvae
and mealworm bolognese for dinner these
are the environmentally friendly meals
we can look forward to
bon appetit milk made from fly
larva well that's only slightly more
grotesque than almond milk at least but
this is what the elites want for us the
un too has come out to promote bug
eating
overall the future they imagine for us
is one where we're living in our pod
home the size of a shipping container
eating cockroaches for breakfast and
wearing medical masks whenever we leave
the house
they want us all to live like um like
like we're like we're the last survivors
in a post-apocalyptic hellscape
basically
that's the ideal vision of the future in
their minds
and i find their vision repugnant
especially when it comes to the meal
plan
first of all it's it's not necessary to
eat bugs in order to save the planet
you're not going to change the weather
by eating bugs i shouldn't have to say
that
the claim being advanced by these people
and this is no straw man it's actually
what they believe
the claim is that if you eat crickets
for lunch enough times
there will be fewer hurricanes it's the
weirdest form of magical thinking
because as the logic goes cows
fart and burp a lot and that's helping
to cause weather-related catastrophes
and it's also melting the ice caps
so we have to look for a less flatulent
food source
but but not only is this ridiculous not
to mention a form of body shaming
towards the poor cows
but it's also it also ignores the
tastier solution
which is eat more cows and eat them
faster
so they have less time to fart second
we're told that bugs are a sustainable
resource
you know we don't have to worry about
running out they say that now anyway
we all know that once everyone starts
eating bugs it's only a matter of time
before they tell us that our bug
chomping ways are causing a bug shortage
and now we have to start getting our
nutrients by eating dirt popsicles and
drinking smoothies made from pond scum
in our own urine or something
but also more to the point even if bugs
are sustainable
so is our current diet we aren't running
out of food
there are people in this country and
certainly across the world who need food
but
that's that's a matter of distribution
not supply
it's similar to the idea that the world
is overpopulated and we're running out
of space
but that's not the case at all we have
plenty of space in fact
the entire population of the world could
fit inside the state of texas
if we wanted to the problem is in how
the space we have
is utilized we tend to crowd ourselves
like sardines into cities
while leaving huge swaths of land empty
so we're doing a pretty bad job of using
the space available
that's the point just as we may be doing
a subpar job in some cases
of using resources but but that's not
the same thing as running out
third most importantly has already
covered eating bugs is disgusting
it is beneath us as civilized people
we are too high on the food chain to
reduce ourselves to that
barbarity the push to make us eat bugs
is anti-human and it's degrading
there's a reason why we are viscerally
repulsed
by the thought of eating bugs or even
just the sight of bugs
they're dirty they're disease infested
they're gross
they are pests not cuisine you call an
exterminator when you have bugs in your
house you don't look up recipes
when your kid comes to you and tells you
there's a spider there's room you tell
them to bring you a shoe not the garlic
powder
in summary bugs are meant to be stomped
on and destroyed
not put into your mouth you sick freaks
and so eating bugs is canceled
today and we'll leave it there thanks
for listening
thanks for watching have a great day
[Music]
godspeed the matte wall show is produced
by sean hampton
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
brazil transforms christ the redeemer
into a massive
dr fauci eric clapton complains of a
brutal reaction to the covid vaccine and
france bans woke language check it out
on the michael knowles show